the Democratic Party were on full
display last night in the second of two
presidential debates the generational
divide was front and center you could
say with younger Democrats finding flaws
in the resumes of more established
candidates the front-runner in the polls
that's former Vice President Joe Biden
took the brunt of it with senator Kamala
Harris hitting him the hardest ed
O'Keefe is in Miami where he covered the
the debate Edie from where you were
sitting what can you tell us about that
moment between Biden and Harris well
luck Tony that exchange came after the
vice president's recent comments about
working with segregationist senators in
the 1970s it was a heated moment
probably the most memorable of the night
Thursday's democratic debate sparked
plenty of fireworks hey guys you know
what America does not want to witness a
food fight they want to know how we're
gonna put food on their table when the
topic shifted to race the fight became
personal it was hurtful to hear you talk
about the reputations of two United
States senators who built their
reputations and career on the
segregation of race in this country
Harris also took aim at Biden's position
in the 1970s and 80s when he opposed the
federal government's policy of busing to
help desegregate schools there was a
little girl in California who was part
of the second class to integrate her
public schools and she was bused to
school every day and that little girl
was me if we want to have this campaign
litigated on who supports civil rights
and whether I did or not I'm happy to do
that I was a public defender I didn't
become a prosecutor
do you agree today that you were wrong
to oppose busing in America though do
you agree I did not oppose busing in
America what I opposed is busing ordered
by the Department of Education that's
what I opposed not a failure of states
to enjoy public schools in America Biden
the current frontrunner was a popular
target what
the differences that Joe and I have in
our record is Joe voted for that war I
helped lead the opposition to that wall
Joe Biden was right when he said it was
time to pass the torch to a new
generation of Americans 32 years ago I'm
still home out of that torch mayor Pete
Budaj was asked why there is it more
diversity on his South Bend Indiana
police force because I couldn't get it
done my community is in anguish right
now because of an officer-involved
shooting a black man Eric Logan killed
by a white officer and I am determined
to bring about a day when a white person
driving a vehicle and a black person
driving a vehicle when they see a police
officer approaching feels the exact same
thing and all the candidates agreed the
border of the United States into a
symbol of hostility the president's
immigration policies have to go I will
release children from cages
I would not be spending money on day one
we take out our executive order pen and
we were sent every damn thing on this
issue that trouble has stopped moments
after that dramatic exchange between
Biden and Harris on race her campaign
tweeted out this picture of her as a
little girl a sign that she had
pre-planned the use of that line of
attack and the sparring didn't end there
one senior Biden campaign aide said it
was a quote low blow for the senator to
bring up the former vice president's
stance on busing and desegregation the
Harris campaign said it's personal for
her and that the vice president should
apologize
Anthony Edie thank you